[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so verließ
welt heute gibt es ein sehr schnelles
und sehr leckeres rezept denn ich habe
einen no bail out of it tk geboten
ich strich durch einen kühlschrank
kuchen ohne backen aus oreo keksen und
schokolade navis auferstanden spricht
die spülmaschine wieder mit uns egal
lacht davon stören
der kuchen ist super einfach denn man
hat einen keks schicht dann kommt der
focus im kühlschrank und dann wird in
der zwischenzeit eben diese leckere
schokoladencreme vorbereitet und
wirklich super schnell und sehr einfach
wahnsinnig gesund natürlich er aber
trotzdem sehr lecker deswegen zeige ich
euch jetzt einfach mal die zutaten und
startet gleich für den glücklosen
brauche ich drei model click sind 100
gramm butter 50 km herren schokolade und
für die cremige füllung brauch ich
jeweils 250 gramm frischkäse quark und
mascarpone 150 gramm heroin schokolade
100 gramm puderzucker etwas sonne legt
und später etwas cacau zum bestreuen
erster stelle ich jetzt den boden her
natürlich darf er nämlich jetzt die oreo
kekse und falls ihr keine kekse nehmen
möchtet könnt ihr auch ganz normaler
schokokekse zum beispiel nehmen damit
sei dann aber ein bisschen mehr butter
einberechnen denn ich habe hier einen
keks die befüllung mit drin
und die werde ich jetzt auch gleich mit
der butter schmelzen
beim nächsten grand nehme ich hier
einmal die füllung raus und die füllung
kommt jetzt in den topf und erhebt
kompliziert in sehr kleiner aber ihr
könnt die kekse auch ganz einfach in
einen gefrierbeutel geben und mit einem
aufbruch statt überrollen
dann könne das ganze auch verkleinern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die kekse fenster pulsiert und hier habe
ich inzwischen auch schon mit butter mit
der orgel klicks füllung geschmolzen er
noch bei niedriger stufe
jetzt kann man hier den herd ausmachen
und hier gebe ich jetzt noch die
schwarze haare schokolade mit einem
anteil von über 60% und dadurch schmeckt
wie eben richtig schokolade die
schokolade darf jetzt hier noch ein
bisschen schmerzen und dann wurde ich
gleich die glücklosen im kreis
[Musik]
st
[Applaus]
[Musik]
st
immer habe ich jetzt gut verrührt jetzt
habe ich mir meine backform also packen
werde ich ihn zwar nicht aber ich
brauchte meine form habe sie eine
plattform mit leben posen das heißt hier
in der mitte kann ich den boden einfach
herausnehmen und es ist auch wirklich
sehr praktisch damit ich später den
google ist nicht raus stücken wir können
jetzt entweder aus oder tat form nehmen
oder auch eine springform oder zwischen
auch einen ganz normalen bakri und da
hat man einfach einen geraden abschluss
und ich finde es hier ganz hübsch mit
diesen grenzen abschluss die form fertig
jetzt ganz kurz ein bisschen mit wachs
rems trail und ich legte dann immer auch
ganz gerne auf einen trockenen retter da
würde ich sie transportieren kann denn
wenn ihr später ihr den kuchen drin habt
und aussehen sind fingern dran kommt
peter koren eben nach oben
das kommt jetzt die masse rein und wird
dann schön platt gedrückt auch bis zum
rand
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die kekse wird schön an gedrückt und
dann müsst ihr auch wirklich darauf
achten wie fest andrücken damit der
kuchen später einfach nicht bewusst
ich stelle es jetzt kurz in den
kühlschrank etwa eine halbe stunde bis
der boden schon fest wird die restlichen
zutaten stelle ich noch mal kurz im
kühlschrank und dann geht's gleich
weiter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der keks wurde ist gut für euch gekillt
und jetzt hier die herren schokolade
schon einmal geschmolzen
über einem warmen aber nicht mehr
kochende wasser war jetzt werden sie
zutaten für die creme verwirrt das heißt
in dem sich entweder für stets zuerst
oder muster boden befindet egal
und beim frischkäse immer darauf achten
dass wir so programm stufen frischkäse
nehmen denn wenn zum beispiel ein
vertreter ist dann wer die creme einfach
nicht so schön fest und kommt viel
schokolade mit rein und wird damit ihr
kurz berührt da kann sich so alles schön
verbinden
[Musik]
die restlichen super mit rein also quark
und in meinem fall ist mascarpone und
zucker geht jetzt nach bedarf dazu das
heißt wenn ich es gerne etwas hermann
stotter weniger zucker würde gerne sein
soll dann müssen mehr zu kommen und wann
der auch einfach noch mit ab
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie kann die creme so wie sie ist
entweder einfach einstreichen mit einem
löffel zum beispiel und eine schöne
wischtechnik machen hat mit dem löffel
rücken oder nimmt einen spritzbeutel du
bist da an der lochmühle dran und bleibt
eine kleine tour auftritten der sprit
wird auch im flug gedreht und deswegen
achte immer darauf ihnen nicht zu voll
zu machen da man ansonsten verkleckern
seitlich für die restliche menge gleich
noch auf
und jetzt werden wir einfach kleine
tupfen hier drauf spritzen und die tat
damit befüllen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und die torte ist mit 750 und fertig
gibt's jetzt nochmals etwa eine halbe
stunde in den kühlschrank und dann bist
du bist kvb sport und verwirrt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt buchen bereits und dem wettkampf
probieren
es ist schon in den startlöchern fahrt
fort ich noch dran gedacht beschreitet
mithalten wenn du möchtest kannst noch
ein paar hin werden dazu nehmen oder was
man eben gerade da hab ich ihr von
herzen gemacht presse und soziales
liebsten würde ich schon verstanden was
macht ihr kleiner hund genau dieser
offensive diese tags boden dann diese
gremien und der boden ist das schön süß
durch die oberhexe deswegen habe ich in
erfüllung ist nicht so viel zucker aber
man kann da natürlich selber bestimmen
und schauen aus einem am besten schmeckt
orange me a river kuchen ja das ist ein
herber leute jetzt allerdings stimmt
nicht also ich genau wo die süßen
herbert und also für mich perfekt und da
ein paar hindernisse oder erst bei uns
so etwas zeit perfekt machen
auch wenn du was backen könnte wenn es
geht macht ein backhaus drüber keiner so
genau aber ist dass sein flügels und
seither mehr zulassen als kakaopulver
deswegen wirklich bad kakaopulver und
falls ihr dieses leckere rezept auch
nach machen wollt vor allem geht es und
super schnell und einfach dann geht auch
tennis - block gegeben und ich wünsche
euch jetzt schon mal ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen
ihr braucht keinen kuchen dafür und
so einfach und so lecker
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kritik
[Musik]
[Applaus]
augenthaler ein wirklich sehr dicke
entschuldigung also ich also eher noch
zunehmen roos abteilung ich war ein
rechtsberater bei ikea monate statt